SUBURBAN.
OFF THE GLOVE OVER STOLARZ INTO
THE CORNER
>> GETTING THIS THROUGH AND IT
JUST BOUNCES  OUT. A 1-0
PITTSBURGH LEAGUE LEAD. BY STOL.
CR
SENT BEHIND THE NET IN THE
BATTLE FOR
HE ANTICIPATED THENT TO GO BACK
BREAKAWAY BID.
THE GRAVI MOP?
>> ON
THE POWER-PLAY.
HERE TAKING AN OPP>> INTERESTIN
THE DUCKS.KS
AND LOOK AT HIM SETTING THE
SCREEN OUT IN 2-0. THEY HAVE
BEEN QUITE AGGRESSIVE DURING TH
COLLIDING BELOW THE
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING SOME OF TH
THINGS ON  ONE.
THEY HAVE COME A LONG WAY IN
ORDER TO GET ACROSS
THIS FF
THE LINE FRESH OFF THE BENCH.LA.
>> PIN THEM AGAINST THE BOARDS
SO THEY CAN JUMP BACK INTO THE
PLAY. THINKING IT AHEA
AHEAD.
>> THAT LINE HAS SCORED EVERY
SINGLE GOAL IN THIS GAME.